universities are obsessed they say was
stamping out harassment they've got
whole programs dedicated to that but not
all harassment some was fine it turns
out Ryan wolf is a student at Wake
Forest University of North Carolina he
says he's faced repeated harassment
verbal and racial harassment for his
views school officials though say
they're not gonna do anything about it
probably cuz they don't like his views
mine wolf joins us tonight Ryan what
happened thanks for having me on Tucker
so back before the 2016 election we had
a panel talk that was hosted by the
College Republicans wake the vote and
the Wake Forest Review which is the
conservative publication on our campus
and kind of before during and after this
event there were messages about me on
social media and in group chats and that
were kind of trying to intimidate me and
then after the event I was handed a box
of saltine crackers and in a group chat
during the event a student photoshopped
my face onto a cracker and so our school
has fairly strict verbal abuse
harassment and I by the way just
applause I assume that's a that's a slur
against Rhett Nissa T correct yes that's
I how it was intended absolutely and so
we have pretty strict rules about
harassment at our school which you know
clearly don't abide by the First
Amendment but we were trying to hold all
students to the same standard so I
reported the conduct actually at the
behest of one of my professors who used
to be an MSNBC host Melissa harris-perry
and so I sent in these reports and the
university basically after several weeks
gave me these options and I asked to
press charges kind of open a school
judicial case against the students who
handed me the box of crackers and
Photoshop my face onto a cracker after
several weeks I was told in many words
because our teen of students Adam
Goldstein really isn't a frank person
that president Trump's election somehow
justified their behavior even though the
incident happened before Election Day
and that if I brought a judicial case it
would make things worse for me we were
heading into finals week of any of this
Matt
stur I just wanted this to be over wait
so who's this Dean Dean Goldstein said I
just wanna make sure I'm not miss Cara
craziness said that the president's
elections somehow justified this attack
on you yeah he doesn't say things and
short sentences like that but what I
took away from that part of the
conversation was that he was trying to
justify their behavior because it was a
response to the election President Trump
how did I mean that's that's it I don't
even know what to say what doesn't make
any sense no it doesn't and I assume
that I didn't ever do this if you'd been
a different kind of person this would
have been swiftly punished I assume
right right exactly
we had a racial slur incident just a few
weeks ago and let me be clear I'm not
equating what was said by this girl to
what was said about me but that student
was asked to leave our school about two
days later this took several weeks and
they wouldn't even open a judicial case
about harassment even just kind of
leaving the race party so Dean Dean
Goldstein didn't say in that case what
Barack Obama was elected president you
know nine years ago so it's sort of
understandable that people might do that
he that that wasn't the excuse he gave
in that case I assume right
oh no yeah well this incident just
happened a few weeks ago here but yet no
it makes no sense I told him in that
meeting that you know individuals have
to be held accountable for their
individual actions under the rules we
have at the school and you know if I had
it my way we would just abide by the
First Amendment and we wouldn't have all
these rules but I know I can have these
strict if we're gonna have these strict
rules in this bias reporting system then
everyone needs to be held accountable
the exact same way Ryan I really
appreciate how brave you are to come on
and how clearly you express that and in
a way you're a credit to Wake Forest
because you're impressive but the school
is not is obviously not living up to its
own standards so thanks for telling us
about it I appreciate ya thanks for
having me on